c'était les deux derniers territoires
clés de cette élection
l'arizona et loïs caunes sinon recompter
les voix de leurs électeurs et confirmé
la victoire de joe biden dans chacun des
deux états une défaite symbolique pour
les républicains le risque en chine
avaient voté majoritairement trump en
2016 l arizona bascule dans le giron des
démocrates pour la première fois depuis
près de 25 ans voter est l'un des droits
est l'une des responsabilités les plus
importants de notre démocratie et je
tiens à remercier les habitants de
l'arizona d'avoir fait entendre leur
voix et d'avoir voté en nombre record
les votes ont été compilés les quinze
comté ont tous certifiés leurs résultats
dans la foulée les partisans de donald
trump sont descendus dans la rue comme
ici à phoenix capitale de l'arizona pour
soutenir leur candidat les recours du
président sortant devant les tribunaux
ne sont pas terminées en arizona il est
possible de contester les résultats même
après validation
pour ce qui est du risque on thin trump
balaie ces résultats d'un revers de main
le recomptage du winch consignes n'est
pas fait pour trouver des erreurs de
comptage mais pour trouver des personnes
qui ont voté illégalement et cette
affaire sera portée devant les tribunaux
une fois le recomptage terminé lundi ou
mardi
nous avons trouvé de nombreux votes
illégaux restez connectés
les avocats de donald trump ont déjà
contesté les résultats électoraux en
arizona en géorgie dans le michigan le
nevada et dernière étant en date en
pennsylvanie des recours rejeté à chaque
fois celui qui est toujours locataire de
la maison-blanche multiplie les coups
d'éclat ce dimanche sur la chaîne
conservatrice fox news
il a même accusé le fbi d'être mêlé au
scrutin c'est de la fraude
et c'est tout quant au fbi au ministère
de la justice je ne sais pas il se
pourrait qu'il soit mêlé à ça c'est tout
de même incroyable que tous ces gens
puissent en tirer comme ça avec la
fraude qu'il y ait eu partout personne
n'est venu me voir pour me dire au fait
le fbi a coincé les auteurs de cette
machination tout cela alors qu'une
échéance cruciale pour le pays approche
le 14 décembre les représentants de
chacun des 50 états américains
devront formellement procéder à
l'élection du candidat démocrate
si le choix jo bèye 2 n'est confirmé
l'ex-vice-président de barack obama
entrera en fonction le 20 janvier
prochain